things are looking really bad for the
left we already knew that things were
bad for the left they are down in the
midterm polls they are down on pretty
much every single issue in the country
they're down on job performance
but this weekend took things to a whole
new level
there was supposed to be
a major pro-abortion protest in new york
city on saturday this was going to be
the 2022 version of the women's march
all the more urgent because the supreme
court just leaked the decision to
overrule roe versus wade
this march was going to be historic
and here is what the local new york
outlet the gothamist had to say
hundreds upon hundreds of abortion
rights supporters marched from brooklyn
to manhattan on saturday in one of the
several mass demonstrations around the
country protesting the presumed
impending end to roe vs wade
hundreds upon hundreds
the population of new york city is over
eight million more than three quarters
of new yorkers vote democrat even lots
of new york republicans support legal
abortion
if abortion were as popular as the
establishment propagandists claim there
should have been
a million people in the streets
conservatively there should have been a
million people in the streets if this
were the fight for women's essential
rights as the libs are claiming we
should have expected to see
what at the very least a few hundred
thousand people out there
but we didn't see millions
we didn't see hundreds of thousands we
didn't see tens of thousands apparently
we didn't even see thousands
which would still have been pretty
pathetic by the way if it were only
thousands in a city of over 8 million
according to new york local news it was
hundreds of people who showed up to
rally for killing babies democrats are
looking to the overrule of roe v wade as
the last best hope that they have to
motivate voters for the midterms in an
otherwise catastrophic year
if this weekend's nationwide flop is any
indication
they're going to have to hope for
something else i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from christoph
rodriguez who says i wonder if joe will
help hunter get some baby formula for
the grandchild he refuses to acknowledge
that is a really
harsh
tough
accurate thing to say this should be a
national scandal and is it is probably
the single most surprising shocking
aspect of the biden administration to me
is that joe's whole image is he's he's
just nice old joe he's just good old
grandpa joe just nice old guy the man
has a grandchild who a granddaughter
whom he will not acknowledge could you
imagine being that little granddaughter
you know that your grandpa is the
president of the united states he's old
nice guy joe and he refuses to
acknowledge you in any way that's that
is an actual scandal but of course you
won't hear about it
in the news because the left is the
especially right now the left is waging
a war on babies in terms of feeding the
babies in terms of letting the babies
live that's why you got to check out 40
days for life with the court's potential
overruling of roe v wade you might think
the abortion fight is coming to an end
not even close abortion legislation
returning to the states means the only
real battle is just beginning and that
is
why it's so important to check out 40
days for life okay there is no group in
america better positioned than 40 days
for life to help fight this battle 40
days for life has 1 million volunteers
throughout the country including
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you may be surprised to hear
their largest presence is actually in
the country's blue states with
california being the biggest state their
vigils have closed many abortion
facilities in america nearly half of
those facilities were in liberal states
where abortion will continue to remain
legal after the fall of roe from san
francisco to chicago to seattle not
exactly pro-life areas volunteers have
guided abortion workers to have a change
of heart and to quit their jobs as this
issue gets out of dc finally 40 days for
life is effectively changing hearts and
minds in the grassroots of the
post-abortion movement check out their
locations podcast their new book what to
say when the complete guide to
discussing abortion at 40daysforlife.com
speaking of all these important issues
in the country do not miss your chance
to engage with us live on these issues
we've got daily wire backstage live
tickets are on sale now dailywire.com
ryman to get your tickets today
do not wait these tickets are selling
very fast daily wire backstage live
ramen auditorium in nashville on june
29th we will see you there
democrats are completely losing the
messaging war
usually at least for probably most of my
life democrats have won the messaging
war because they control all of the
media and hollywood and the news and all
of it and publishing and so they
generally they've won the messaging war
they are totally losing it now here is
here is the best line that the democrats
have come up with in in the last
two years at least to to attack the
republicans to to aim all of the public
vitriol at the conservatives
in a sense
i never expected
let me
say this carefully
i never expected
the
ultra
mega republicans
who seem to control the republican party
now
to have been able to control the
republican party
i i never anticipated that happening
the ultra mega republicans a lot of
people thought this was just a line that
joe biden came up with on the spot and
it's not a great line and it actually
makes us seem kind of cool
that image is cool right ultra maga what
does maga means make america great again
i'm ultra i'm ultra i'm super mega i'm
yes i'm here to defend truth justice and
the american way it seems like kind of a
cool thing but whatever you know joe
biden he's he's definitely lost a few
steps he just used this line it's
probably going to backfire but he came
up with it on the spot right
no actually it turns out according to
the washington post
that line was workshopped
that line was researched
a progressive group
spent six months
researching the killer new line to use
against the republicans they took a lot
of money to do this and the best thing
that they could come up with was ultra
maga
this is like out of a
saturday night live sketch if saturday
night live were funny and even slightly
right wing this would be an snl sketch
where you go you say you got all the
genius consultants in the room they say
all right mr president we're in the war
room we've got to come up with the
soaring rhetoric this high oratory this
killer political messaging to go after
your opponents okay what have you got
boys well we've spent
zillions of your dollars and focus
groups and
ultra maga wow good job geniuses i'm
glad all those ivy league degrees are
paying off this is
good please use it ultra maga i'm
michael knowles this is the ultra magaz
show let's see how that see how that
turns out in november folks i don't
think it's going to turn out very well
the libs who had been so
precise with language and they still
remain precise with language but they
had been so effective at manipulating
language for a century i wrote a whole
book on this my
number one national bestseller
speechless controlling words controlling
minds thanks to all of you rose up the
charts uh the book is about how the left
very effectively has wielded language to
take over the whole culture
i think they've lost their gift or
they're they're at least in a rut right
now the pro-choice caucus
of the democrats
it's there used to be
a little more
of a distinction between left and right
republican democrat pro-choice
pro-life
that's kind of gone away now left
democrat pro-abortion it's all the same
thing so the pro-choice caucus has sent
out important abortion messaging do's
and don'ts and don'ts reportedly so what
they're saying is
there is harmful language and we've got
to change it to make it more palatable
to the public the harmful language is
choice
previously you'll remember the the word
for abortion was abortion or infanticide
or killing then they said no we've got
to call it choice that's going to make
it softer and better but now choice has
been poisoned
so now they're saying instead of choice
you have to say decision
it's a woman's decision that's what
they're saying the helpful languages the
harmful language is that we need to
reduce abortion and make it safe legal
and rare that was the line that the
clintons came up with the helpful
language is safe legal and accessible
and accessible forget about rare it's
the opposite of rare actually we need to
make it easily accessed unwanted
pregnancy that's harmful it makes it
seem like we don't want babies
unexpected pregnancy is better
and then we don't want the unexpected
pregnancy and we kill the baby
harmful language conscience clause or
protections to to get out of some of the
radical abortion legislation
the helpful language they say refusal of
care slash denial of care laws because
killing a baby is care according to the
abortion pro-abortion left
then finally harmful languages back
alley abortions and coat hangers they
think this is this is probably harmful
in that
it paints a very ugly picture but also
it just didn't happen it's not real it's
describing an allegedly widespread
problem that did not exist the helpful
language they say is criminalizing
health care
you're criminalizing health care by not
letting people kill their kids
why do they have to do this the reason
they have to do this was explained by
the harvard psychologist stephen pinker
in the phrase euphemism treadmill i also
talk about this in my book speechless
which is coming out in paperback next
month by the way so it should be fun
that will give us another chance to jump
up to the top of the charts and have the
new york times ignore us on their
best-seller list
the euphemism treadmill refers to a
problem that the left has in particular
which is the left will use a euphemism
to
to
deceive people about their harmful
policies so instead of saying killing
babies they'll say
choice or what women's healthcare
and but eventually
that term
the new term takes on the same negative
color it's the same negative
characteristics and and
sense of the old term because the
reality of the situation has not changed
and so
you end up in a situation where you just
need to come up with a new
new euphemism
you'll notice this with certain
disabilities
let's say someone is disabled that this
is
a lot of people are disabled there's
nothing shameful in being disabled but
it's not a preferable condition no one
wants to be disabled and so you have a
word like [ __ ] [ __ ] then takes on
a negative connotation because it's it's
a condition that is undesirable no one
wants to have that condition and so then
it becomes handicapped but then handicap
takes that on and then it becomes handy
capable
and then handy capable takes it on and
then it becomes differently able and
they have they have to change the
euthanism every six months it seems
because
the the condition that it describes is
is one that people
still don't want to have for themselves
so that would be a kind of neutral
description of that what about in
politics when when the libs are trying
to deceive everybody
well that's what you see with abortion
especially it's a woman's right to
choose it's women's healthcare it's
reproductive freedom it's choice it's
decision it's this it's that no well the
thing you're describing is not only
undesirable the thing you're describing
is shameful the thing you're describing
is sinful the thing you're describing is
deeply immoral you're talking about
killing a baby there's no way that you
can put lipstick on that pig and
convince us all that it's marilyn monroe
it's a horrible thing and so good job
dems change the language all you want
six months from now you're going to be
in the same situation the more effective
strategy would be to change your mind
and stop embracing things that are
obviously wrong don't do it you'll sleep
a lot easier at night okay you'll
definitely sleep a lot easier if you
sleep on bowl and brand sheets right now
go to bowlingbranch.com use promo code
michael bowlin branch not only helps me
sleep better but it also teaches me
things did you know
did you know that thread count is just a
totally made-up number
it's not that it's a made-up number but
it's it's a it's a made-up
meaningful statement you always hear
sheet coming they say we've got a seven
gazillion thread count it doesn't matter
how many threads you've got if the
threads are not of the highest quality
okay so a lot of a lot of sheet
companies they'll say oh you've got all
this thread count but their sheets
aren't aren't any good because the
threads are the threads aren't very high
quality bolon branch uses only the best
100 organic cotton threads on earth for
a superior softness and a better night's
sleep i love these guys i've been
sleeping on bowling branch for years
they're like a drug dealer they gave me
the first first batch for free and now
i've been buying them ever since three
u.s presidents sleep on bowling branch
three us presidents and one of your
favorite podcast posts check it out
right now you get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
visit bowlingbranch.com use promo code
michael that's b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com use promo code michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
why
now
why are the democrats trying to change
all of their language and use these
highly focused grouped
phrases
to to communicate with the public
their their
need to do that right now because they
are harming
vulnerable members of our society in a
very visible way
why is this abortion issue right now the
big issue well in part it's because of
the supreme court decision why is the
supreme court decision
so prominent well because we've got
conservative judges on the court we've
got pro-life laws in mississippi and
pro-life laws in florida why do we have
these pro-life laws why are people
focusing on this issue
more than they have apparently in 50
years
they are because the libs are not as
good at hiding their horrible agenda
they are harming kids not just little
tiny babies in the womb it's easier to
hide that relatively easier to hide that
even with sonograms but now they're
harming kids in kindergarten first grade
second grade that's why you see the
parents movement of virginia that's why
you see the parents movement in florida
the illinois department of child and
family services
is sponsoring a kitty corner
at the pride parade
uh chris ruffo just broke this the
illinois department of children family
services is sponsoring a pridefest kitty
corner featuring drag queen story time
drag kids drag kids dress up so you're
dressing up little boys in in stripper
clothing and putting them in little
stiletto heels and having them dance
around for the sexual pleasure of
perverts and deviants that's just that's
wonderful that's open-minded that's
tolerant and if you oppose that if you
oppose putting kids in sexualized
clothing of the opposite sex why you're
just a closed-minded bigot according to
the government of illinois and they have
a drag show for children as well we all
know that this is completely
disordered and wrong
and then the fight
usually breaks down something like this
conservatives will object to kids being
sexualized and and exposed to all this
absolutely degenerate filth and then the
liberals will come in and they'll say
you're being open-minded stop forcing
your religious views on you you're it's
fine if you think that this is immoral
in your private life but don't you force
your religious views about why we
shouldn't dress up little boys like
they're hookers and have them dance
around on a stage for perverts stop
forcing your religious views on us
and and the conservatives were often
left speechless by the sheer audacity
and mendacity of the claims of the left
but the way to try to shake them into
some
understanding of reality is to point out
that the left is forcing their religious
views on us the clearest religious view
they're forcing here is the religious
view that the soul has nothing to do
with the body and so it is ontologically
possible to be a man trapped in a
woman's body or a woman trapped in a
man's body and that the body has nothing
to do with our true identity and that we
have an obligation
to affirm our own
deeply felt sentiments that we might be
the opposite sex and to reject our body
or to mutilate our body or to dress up
like the opposite sex and that this is a
good thing those are moral claims those
are claims about human nature those are
religious claims and the left is not
merely relegating their religion to the
private sphere like they insist that
christians do and jews do and muslims do
they're making their religious views the
public religion of the united states we
have a public religion because all
states at all times have some kind of
public religion our public religion in
this country from its very earliest days
in the early 17th century up until about
five minutes ago was christianity that
was the public religion with a broad
range of tolerance because there were
disagreements among the various
protestant christian sects and there
were always catholics here from almost
the nation's earliest days there was
some catholic presence in the new world
well
that that's now gone out the window and
the public religion is transgenderism
and the public religion is
lgbt and the public religion is
diversity equity and inclusion the
public religion is multiculturalism and
that public religion makes different
claims about human nature and the
relation of man to state and the
relation of who we are
to our creator
who we are to one another and so they're
going to force that out there and and
the challenge for conservatives
is that we have just spent half a
century at least
em embracing the left's idea of a
separation between church and state
and embracing the left's idea of a
radical kind of religious freedom that
says that you have the right to believe
whatever you want without any
restrictions from the government and
that's not really a conservative
argument and that's not really
traditional in the american
in american history and that's not
really
philosophically coherent and it does it
doesn't really make sense of course
there have to be limits on these things
we don't we don't really believe
that if if you are a member of the
religious group
well i don't even need to make up a
crazy hypothetical example we don't
really believe that if you're a member
of a pagan religious group that
practices human sacrifice that you have
a right to do that
we we don't actually think that that
might be your deeply held religious view
but you don't have a right to do it the
satanists right now are saying that they
part of their religious practice is
abortion which is true that actually is
part of the satanist religious practice
nevertheless
we the people still have the right to
prohibit that and they have no right to
pursue it conservatives need to get a
lot more comfortable talking about
public religion we need to get a lot
more comfortable saying yeah we are
going to legislate morality because all
legislation legislates morality and the
libs have been legislating morality for
the last 50 60 70 years and it's been a
complete disaster for everybody and so
you know what i think we're going to go
back to legislating morality and
everybody's going to be better off for
it
we got to get our confidence back got to
get some i don't know some of those
anatomical features that everyone's
focused on these days i think we need to
grow some of them again too
because the
prevailing
sexual ethic that is that is reigning in
the country and being enforced by the
state is insane in wisconsin right now
is a wisconsin school district that just
filed a title ix
sexual harassment complaint
against middle school students and they
they are filing this complaint against
the students
because the students
used the correct pronoun to refer to one
of their classmates
an investigation into three keel middle
school students has been launched the
school district has filed a title nine
complaint accusing the students of using
incorrect pronouns while addressing
another student punks 11's monique lopez
spoke with the parent of one of the
students in this project education
report
i received a phone call from the
principal over at the elementary school
forewarning me letting me know that i
was going to be receiving an email
with sexual harassment allegations
against my son rosemary rabidu's 13 year
old son braden is one of the three 8th
grade kiel middle school students
accused of sexual harassment
something she disputes he said he's
being allegedly charged with sexual
harassment for not using proper pronouns
some might say or think that you or your
son are against the lgbtq plus community
not at all not at all
there's so much here you could write a
doctoral dissertation about this whole
interview
because
you saw right there at the end the
interviewer says so your 13 year old son
is being charged with sexual harassment
for using the correct pronouns to refer
to a sexually confused classmate
some people would say you're against the
lgbtq community and you see what that
woman says this totally normal mother
who says are you kidding you're accusing
my 13 year old son of sexual harassment
for calling a her a her or a him a hymn
and they said but are you against the
lgbt she said no no we're for lgbt we
love we're we're totally pro-lgbt oh
yeah man absolutely that's our we
worship at the altar of lgbt because
this woman knows that that's part of the
public religion
and she knows that if you contradict the
public religion
you will be called a heretic and you
will be ostracized and you will be
punished
and she knows that so even this woman
who's defending her kid and saying what
you're telling me my 13 year old son has
to use the wrong pronouns to apparently
this one of the students wants the
pronoun to be they or them
which which makes me wonder if the
student has multiple personality
disorder that they think that they have
multiple people inside of them that they
and them which is now being used as a
singular pronoun by very confused people
and the students said i'm not going to
do that and now the students being
punished are you against the lgbt no no
never never no please
now of course if one is a christian
a jew
a muslim
an agnostic person who just sort of
holds on to a traditional sexual ethic
they might
have objections to some
aspects of the lgbt lmnop ideology and
sexual ethic
they
for all of the history
of civilization pretty much their people
would have had legitimate objections to
some of that sexual ethic you are not
permitted to have those objections now
and we're we're being told this is in
the name of neutrality and
open-mindedness and liberality and but
of course it's not
really what the
state has said here
is no you do not have the right to your
religion you do not have the right to
your sexual ethic you do not have the
right to think what you think
actually it's the most close-minded sort
of
sort of uh
regime that one could possibly imagine
and now it's being taken to the height
of absurdity charge then of course
they're going after the 13 year old boys
which is preposterous on the school yard
people say all sorts of mean things but
the kids aren't even saying a mean thing
here they're being punished not for
telling a lie not for being insulting
not for being cruel they're being
punished for telling the truth and
people around the country are looking at
this and they're saying hey whatever it
is
whatever the left is selling we are not
buying if this is what leftism leads to
we're out see you later folks
speaking of sexual issues
uh the women's march you know was this
weekend or was supposed to be this
weekend and a lot a lot didn't really
happen uh
this was all about
or the whole point of it was supposed to
be about defending abortion okay
well we've got a really important daily
wire original documentary out presented
by yours truly called choosing death the
legacy of a row
uh if you
if you want to learn something about
this issue i would not recommend going
out and shouting with the screaming
pro-abortion people at the women's march
i would recommend becoming a daily wire
member watch choosing death the legacy
of roe to hear the facts and to hear the
real stories that the abortion regime
has suppressed for generations here's
the trailer
many times when we
did
this
as we started
patients would
begin crying and
protesting
but once we had begun dilating the
cervix and passing instruments into the
uterus was too late to stop
[Music]
i was handing hush money
to women who we had left pieces of their
baby
we had put these women's lives in
jeopardy we had put their lives at risk
and we were literally giving them a
check for eight hundred dollars
and for a poor woman eight hundred
dollars a lot of money
i mean there have been so many moments
in the last decade plus of going
undercover in abortion clinics myself
and seeing
just heartbreaking things women vomiting
in the hallway of an abortion clinic
crying out in pain the late term
abortionist talking casually
about how they would literally leave a
born alive baby to die or if you deliver
the baby in the toilet then you pick it
up and stuff it in a plastic bag and
bring it to us
babies are being born alive
and the backs of their necks are being
slit
they are being drowned
their necks are being snapped
it's it's happening more often than
people want to think about
these abortion facilities these abortion
providers these doctors
they don't care about these women
and you're just you're realizing it
you're watching in front of your own
eyes play out america's greatest horror
story
which is
how we butcher children
in the name of choice
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
the fight for life has all come down to
this moment go to dailywire.com
choosing help us to expose abortions
full gruesome truth we'll be right back
with a lot more
the libs are losing right now they're at
least losing ground with the people
because we can see what they're doing we
can see what they're doing in the
schools that was first opened to us
during covid19 during the lockdowns
where parents could see on a screen what
their kids were being taught that's
because of social media which though
social media tries to suppress some
awful clips of the libs they don't often
totally succeed at that is because we're
seeing what their euphemistic abstract
policies choice and affirmation and
we're seeing what that means in real
life there's a video brought to us by
our great friends over at libs of tick
tock of a
queer surgeon that's his his
name on
twitter at queer surgeon this guy blair
peters bragging about performing quote
gender affirming mastectomies top
surgeries for three young adults and
adolescents in a day sometimes and by
that he means lopping off the perfectly
healthy breasts of teenage girls of
these young girls he brags about it on
video
i'm here to clarify and speak some
truths about what's happening with
gender affirming care and adolescence um
most of the bills that are going through
right now aim to limit this care for
people under the age of 18. and there's
this false narrative that a lot of
teenagers are having gender affirming
surgery
most of the teenagers that are having
surgery are getting chest surgery and
most of that is happening before 18
because these individuals didn't have
access to early enough medical treatment
so
using surgery as sort of this false
narrative to attack gender affirming
care as a whole is not correct the truth
is that by limiting access to medical
care with some of these bills you're
actually going to cause more people to
need gender affirming surgical care
that's his explanation he's saying look
so the reason that i'm lopping off the
perfectly healthy sexual organs of
teenage girls left and right in medical
experiments the likes of which we've
never seen before in the world we're
doing this because they're not letting
us pump five-year-olds full of hormones
and and eight-year-olds full of
cross-sex hormones and puberty blockers
so if they would just let us do that
then i wouldn't have to lop off the
perfectly healthy organs of the
teenagers okay and that's why it's so
important for us to to pass these laws
that will that will uh
ensure our right to to sexually mutilate
little kids that's what he's saying in a
just society this guy would be in prison
okay his name is his name blair peters
in a just society this man would not be
practicing medicine he would not be
bragging about he he posted this video
it's not it wasn't some undercover
investigation he himself posted this
video to tick tock which none of us
would have seen because tic toc is all
young people and obviously skews to the
left
and then lives of tiktok reposts it to
twitter and we get to see it this guy
should be in prison there should be laws
against the sort of thing that he is
doing
and obviously there should be laws
against the sort of thing that he is
advocating which is even more radical
and there's no throw your hands up in
the air guys there's no bury your head
in the sand there's no you do you i'm
not going to force my views on you
either we're going to live in a country
that sexually mutilates little kids or
not the law is going to say one thing or
the other either we're allowed to do
that or we're not allowed to do that i
think we should not be allowed to do
that i think it's wrong i think it's
wrong because of biology and because of
philosophy and because of morality and i
think it's wrong in part because we just
all know it's wrong and even people who
are not the most educated or
sophisticated or read the latest
journals we just know it's wrong to do
that to rot lop the breasts off of
teenage girls it's just wrong right and
we know it and we're right to know that
and we don't need to second-guess that
and we don't need to try to deny the
intuitions that happen to be correct and
we have the right in a self-government
if the if indeed we live in a
self-government to pass laws against
that and to criminalize this and if this
creep if this pervert blair peters
decides to keep pushing this radical
destructive sexual ideology on innocent
little kids then that guy should go to
jail and there's nothing wrong with that
okay speaking of prison we have to get
to
i guess probably the biggest story of
the weekend
this awful shooting in buffalo there was
a guy who went in shot up a supermarket
in buffalo i believe 10 people
are
killed
as always whenever there is a shooting
with a potential political or especially
racial motive everybody goes in
instantly and tries to
uh it tries to find out why the guy is
actually on the other team that's what
always happens right the left goes in
they try to make him on the right and
then the right goes in and tries to make
him on the left i guess actually the
first thing that happens is the media
will go in and decide whether or not to
cover the story and if the story
corresponds with their predetermined
political narrative then they will cover
it so if the story is about a white
racist killing black people they will
cover it they will make that a a huge
national news story uh the president of
the united states
as in this case we'll go and visit and
make a big media spectacle out of it
if the uh story contradicts the
narrative if it is say a black racist
killing white people or black racist
killing asian people they will bury it
they will not talk about it that's what
happened with the waukesha killing
that's what happened with the new york
city subway shooting there were news
stories for about 24 hours and then when
the narrative did not fit the media's
preconceived
political agenda then they just buried
that news story the president didn't
have time to go to waukesha the
president didn't have time to go to new
york city but now he will okay
that is just what always is going to
happen i thought candace owens had the
best take on this she said don't forget
folks the media don't care about white
people the media don't care about black
people they the media only care about
power and so that's that's going to
affect all of the coverage here then the
next thing that happens is that everyone
tries to go in and make the guy on the
other side and so the left is obviously
doing that to the right right now and
the right to some degree is doing it
with the left too
i read the purported
manifesto of this killer i don't see any
reason to read his thesis on why he
committed this crime i don't see any
reason to say the guy's name i don't see
any reason to give him the air time and
fame that he is obviously seeking uh but
i i i will go in just to clarify things
in terms of who he is and
and what some of his motivations were
not what he was necessarily hoping to
achieve
uh
or his you know grand political thesis
but just what might have motivated him
because you're going to hear a lot of
misinformation
certainly from the left but you know
maybe some from the right to so he says
are you a christian
no i do not ask god for salvation by
faith nor do i confess my sins to him i
personally believe there is no afterlife
so if anyone tells you this is about
christianity or christian nationalism or
christian whatever that's not true he
says it's not true and he seems sincere
are you a fascist yes he says he's a
fascist are you white supremacist yes
are you an anti-semite yes
i wish all jews to hell he says this is
more evidence that he's not christian
because if you're a christian what you
want is for jews to
accept jesus and go to heaven and be in
heaven forever with everybody
not just jews but
everybody on earth you you are praying
for everyone's salvation this guy's
obviously not doing that he's wishing
someone to go to hell
are you a neo-nazi he says i support
neo-nazism are you a conservative no so
they're going to say this guy's a
conservative he explicitly says i'm not
a conservative are you right-wing he
says depending on the definition sure
are you left-wing depending on the
definition sure and this is a point that
i always try to make you always hear the
left invoking nazis and hitler and they
say the and they call everyone to the
right of hillary clinton a nazi and and
hitler and then sometimes you'll hear
people on the right come back and say
actually hitler was a leftist actually
nazism is a left-wing ideology it's not
a right-wing ideology and the answer is
not everything breaks down on the left
or right
the answer is left and right which is a
political framework that comes out of
the french revolution and
describes the people who defended the
church and the monarchy on the right and
the people who defended the radicals and
the atheists on the left and the
revolutionaries on the left that doesn't
apply to every single political
situation hitler and the nazis had some
aspects of their political movement that
were right-wing that had some aspects of
the political movement that were
traditionalists and had there were
traditionalists themselves and had some
aspects of their political movement that
were left-wing the rampant atheism the
anti-christianity
the modernism the modern scientism all
those things were
the the statism that those things were
aspects of the left and so you you
really can't i know that's the least
satisfying answer of all but you
actually can't categorize
nazis or lots of political movements on
just the left or on just the right
he says are you a socialist uh depending
on the definition so he says in a way i
actually am a socialist uh you're not
going to hear that from the media what
does that mean it means you can't neatly
characterize this guy did you always
hold these views he says when i was 12 i
was deep into communist ideology from
age 15 to 18. i consistently moved
further to the right on the political
compass i fall in the mild moderate
authoritarian left category so that's
the category where you would lump stalin
or somebody in again this is going to
contradict the media narrative so you're
not going to hear about it and probably
the media are going to attack me for
even reading this but i think it's
important to read this
if you want to understand what the
motivations are
not because this guy is some grand
political thinker who should in any way
be emulated but rather because we know
that the media are going to lie about
this and so we want to be able to form
our own conclusions if we had a
trustworthy media we wouldn't have to do
that
and then this this might be the most
interesting aspect here tactically uh
this this looney tune says
won't your attack result in calls for
the removal of gun rights in the united
states it says yes that is the plan all
along you said you would fight for to
protect your rights and constitution
soon the time will come so he's saying
yes actually the reason that i'm i'm
using these guns and in the manifesto he
posts all sorts of information about the
guns is to get gun control because he
says that if there's gun control this
will really irritate the people who
defend the second amendment and this
could increase the chances of some kind
of war between the left and the right or
the races or whatever
that's
really all i have to say about this uh
there's nothing left to say that isn't
said obviously you know it's very wrong
to kill people it's very wrong to
embrace these insane ideologies
but the rule of thumb
the rule of thumb that is really worth
looking at here
whether you find yourself being
radicalized to the far left or
radicalized to the far right or
radicalized to the far whatever if you
can't place it
there is no end that justifies an
immoral means we we actually were
talking about this
uh last week
or the week before that in in parts of
this guy's
ravings he said he he asked will you
regret this and he says i probably will
yeah i don't i don't you know i don't i
don't bear any ill will toward these
people individually i don't think
they've done anything wrong individually
but my my ideology that i've formed is
such that i'm just gonna suppress that
moral intuition and kill these people
don't do that people do this all the
time usually it doesn't have these sort
of tragic
extreme consequences but people do this
sort of thing all the time they believe
that their ends their political ends
justify immoral means they don't they
don't they don't there is no
end that justifies an immor
almost all the time when you when you
commit an immoral action because you
think that there is some good end that
that will result in it doesn't actually
result in a good end but even if it
could then the immoral means would not
be justified you judge the action on the
action
itself
in a completely separate
sort of version of this a month or so
ago i was with ted cruz at yale and some
kid thought he was going to be funny and
he got up and he said
to end world hunger would you fellate
another man and he thought this was a
really funny question because
if we answered
uh no then we look heartless because we
don't want to end world hunger and if we
answered yes then we just said we would
fellate another man on stage and that
and the kid would have thought that was
funny but i actually didn't think this
was a complicated question
the question was would you commit an
immoral action for an ostensibly good
end
and the answer is no no don't that's
really simple stuff folks and we're
living in the age post machiavelli
we're living in the age where where we
judge everything by these abstract
calculations and utilitarianism and
maximizing the greatest good for the
greatest number even involves cracking a
few eggs to make an omelet
that's morally idiotic that's morally
bankrupt just
just do the right thing okay simple
simple enough
now the moral confusion that we've got
is is spread throughout the political
culture it's spread
throughout especially throughout
academia which is ironic because you
would think the academics would have
some sense of of the reality of the
situation because they're supposed to
spend their lives studying it but that's
not what really happens
do you remember some months ago there
was a chick who was a professor at old
dominion university uh alan walker chick
who now thinks she is a man or some kind
of other
sexual category and uh this this woman
wrote a book called a long dark shadow
minor attracted people and their pursuit
of dignity
uh the the thing that got this gal in
trouble is that she
seemed to want to destigmatize
pedophiles
i use the term minor attracted person or
math uh in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons um first of
all because i think it's important to
use terminology for groups that members
of that group want others to use for
them
and math advocacy groups like before you
act
um have advocated for use of the term
map
they've advocated for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms like pedophile
a lot of people when they hear the term
pedophile they automatically assume that
it means a sex offender
and that isn't true and it leads to a
lot of misconceptions about attractions
toward minors
i've definitely heard the idea that you
brought up though that the use of the
term minor attracted person suggests
that it's okay to be attracted to
children
but using a term that communicates who
someone is attracted to
it doesn't indicate anything about the
morality of that attraction okay so it
doesn't and look we need to call them
maps because we need to destigmatize
this okay and we so
old dominion university had the good
sense to fire this chick because she's
defending pedos and she's trying to
normalize pedophilia as the right has
warned would happen for many years and
we were called kooks and conspiracy
theorists and slippery slopists and now
that's what's going on so
just over the past few days we get an
announcement from johns hopkins
university which is ostensibly a more
prestigious university
saying we're excited to share that alan
walker phd will be joining the moore
center as a postdoctoral fellow on may
25th so
the reason i mentioned johns hopkins as
a more prestigious name brand university
is this chick wasn't punished for trying
to normalize pedos she got a promotion
now of course i have a great deal more
respect for old dominion university than
i do for johns hopkins old dominion
seems to know that it's not right to
normalize pedophilia johns hopkins
doesn't understand that but it shows you
how deep the rot runs that in this sort
of society
things that would have gotten you run
out of town on a rail
not 10 years ago will now not see you
punished now you will get a promotion
because all the incentives are in favor
of that kind of disorder
another thing happened
over the past few days
that the media are not covering you
probably haven't even heard of it
did you know that we're at war
did you know that the united states of
america is at war
i didn't know that i don't remember
the president declaring war i don't
remember the congress declaring war i
don't remember there being a vote on
this i don't remember there being a big
national discussion about this
nevertheless apparently we are at war
according to the democratic majority
leader in the united states house of
representatives who says
this is a time of war and we are at war
with russia
i wish we'd get off this and really
focus on the on the enemy i know there's
a lot of politics here
but we're at war
we need to produce energy
as i told you in
code point is now sending 80 percent
reversing
asia
uh supply to european supply because
they need it because we're at war but
very frankly we're at war
a dictator
has invaded without justification
a friendly country
the ukraine
and they have fought back with
extraordinary valor
we're at war now steny hoyer has been in
congress for about seven billion years
at this point what's funny is he
undercuts his own argument even as he's
describing he's saying a dictator
vladimir putin invaded a friendly
country friendly to whom not obviously
not friendly to russia friendly he means
i think to the united states and to the
west invaded a friendly country uh
without justification i agree with that
i don't think the invasion was justified
at all and and uh putin did that he
invaded the ukraine and because steny
hoyer is so old and he's been around so
long he doesn't realize that the ukraine
is not the name of the country
the ukraine
is a name of a region of the soviet
union a part of russia actually that the
russians refer to ukraine as the ukraine
the ukrainians refer to ukraine as
ukraine because ukraine is its own
sovereign country so this guy is so old
he's so confused he's been around
washington for so long that he actually
undercuts his own argument for being at
war even while he's making it and then
he has the audacity to come out and say
no we the country is at war and you
didn't get to vote on it you
representatives and you the american
people didn't really get to express your
views on it and but too bad we're at war
because i say that we're at war
do you want to go to war
with
a nuclear former superpower
over a territorial dispute that's been
going on for a thousand years do you
want to do that i'm not saying
if if you even raise this question you
will be called pro putin you will be
called a
coward and neville chamberlain you will
be called
all sorts of names
do you
for the entire history of the cold war
we managed to avoid direct war with
russia
we fought little proxy wars but we
managed to avoid
saying that we were in a direct war with
russia because of the threat of nuclear
war and now this old coot has decided in
the twilight of his political career
that he is going to undo all of that and
declare a hot direct war with a nuclear
former superpower that has lots and lots
of missiles aimed at us right now over
ontario territorial dispute
in ukraine
do you think that's a good idea
in order to think that's a bad idea you
don't need to think that putin's
invasion is justified you don't need to
think that
the ukraine should just roll over and
and let it happen you don't need to
think that uh ukraine is
a bad country or that ukraine is a good
country or that any of you don't need to
think you just i think the american
people still get some say in whether or
not we go to war right
russia is not attacking the united
states
this is not an existential threat to the
united so why is this happening
because it actually ties into all the
same things that we've been talking
about from the top of the show that
we've been talking about for weeks now
because the ruling class and the
democratic party is the majority party
in the ruling class and the republicans
are kind of the junior partner some
establishment republicans obviously play
a role in that but they're the junior
partner the democrat party believes that
they do not have accountability to the
voters anymore they don't need to answer
the voters on anything on life on the
economy on energy on immigration on
uneven matters of war
the democrat views right now are
completely opposite to the majority of
the american people and you're seeing
them really underwater in all the polls
the democrats don't seem to care two
explanations for that either they're
just extremely stupid
could be could be i'm not putting it
past them or they don't think it really
matters they don't think that they're
really going to be held accountable on
this point i just watched dinesh
d'souza's new movie 2000 mules about the
rigging that took place in the 2020
presidential election
it's a terrific movie you should go
check it out
it doesn't
it doesn't make the whole argument with
totally definitive everything that the
election was totally definitively stolen
but it makes a pretty good argument
makes a pretty convincing one i would
recommend checking that out and i think
it's a better explanation because i
don't think that the democrats are just
complete idiots i don't
call me charitable say i've gone soft in
my old age i don't think it's that i
think they feel comfortable that they
are going to be able to broadly maintain
their political power and so they don't
need to be answerable to the voters on
really any of these questions they're
going to go out there and they're going
to trans your kids and they're going to
flood your country with foreign
nationals and they're going to destroy
the value of your wealth and they're
going to raise the price of gas and
they're going to kill your energy
industry and they're going to send you
to war and you're not going to get to
say jack diddley squat about it
and now what they're saying there's a
report out
that vladimir putin's sick there have
been lots of reports on this vladimir
putin is sick he's got cancer he's
saying oligarch close to the kremlin was
recorded on tape saying the president is
very ill with blood cancer some people
have said he has parkinson's disease
people have been saying this for years
the evidence for it is pretty weak
they'll say well his face is puffy so
that's how you know he's he's dying and
i don't know i don't really believe any
of the so-called news coming out of this
war in ukraine because there's
propaganda on both sides but let's say
that it is real i'm not saying it he
might be sick he might he might be
a
terminally ill
if so do you think it's a really good
idea to
uh heighten to escalate a war with that
guy do you think that's really smart a
dying desperate man and if it's not real
the reason i i sort of dismiss the
claims that putin is sick or i just i
just don't focus on them when i'm trying
to think about this war is because it it
just
it's so prideful to say that everyone
every other actor in the world all of
our adversaries they're just crazy and
they're just crazy and there's no i'm
not sure that they're just crazy i think
a lot of them are pretty sophisticated
and i think that if if we believe that
they're crazy we're going to put
ourselves at a disadvantage because i
think there are plenty of rational
reasons for russia to invade ukraine
they've done it many times throughout
history and putin's been talking about
doing this for a very long time as well
and i think that if we understand the
rational reasons and not just write all
of our adversaries off as total nuts
it's going to give us a much smarter
foreign policy it's going to allow us to
better rebuff our our adversaries around
the world and that's going to that's
also going to allow the american people
to engage in a debate over how we want
to act
but but of course the ruling class
doesn't want to do that they don't want
to hear from anybody else they don't
want to be told no they don't they don't
want to hear from from any of us and so
that that's the question as we head into
the midterm elections will we still be
permitted to make our voices hurt will
we still be able to do that in the
political process or not i hope we are i
hope there's still i still have some
hope hope's a theological virtue it's a
requirement it's going to take a lot of
work i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show